hello my name is steve jackson um i'm
the associate director of product
applications here at thermo fisher
scientific
and in this in this talk i'm going to
talk to you a little bit about
how you can analyze immuno-oncology
related gene expression patterns using
uh tumor research samples using rfid
tagged tacman panels
and this exploits our new flagship uh
quant studio 67 pro
instrument that has a lot of smart
features which i'll briefly touch on
as a result of these of this talk
so one of the main problems that we're
facing um when when dealing with cancer
is that a tumor sample can be sensitive
to uh
growth deactivation using a number of
immune system checkpoints um there are
several different
these of the checkpoint pathways that
exist there's the the ctla4
there's pdl1 there's there's uh there's
a lot of different uh
met why i won't say a lot but there's
several different checkpoint pathways
but but many times you you are unsure
which of those pathways are going to
work to to inhibit cell growth
um so how can you tell which one is
effective um
one of the ways you can analyze this is
by looking at expression of subsets of
genes and tumor sample
and ex by looking at the substance of
these genes you might be able to say
um which of these pathways might be
effective in inhibiting
growth of these these tumor cells
um thus there's a way to there's a need
to easily analyze gene expression levels
in immune oncology
research subjects research pathways
so um over the course of this talk i'll
basically make use of an experiment we
did
where we obtained 10 colon tumor
and adjacent normal adjacent ffpe
samples
we analyze expression levels of these
genes by looking at two
gene expression signatures that were
defined in publications that came out
recently
these the expression signatures are
associated with with uh immuno
immuno oncological response
and then we correlated differences in
expression signatures of these two
groups of genes um in three different
comparisons
we look at tumor versus normal with
pdl-1 positive staining versus negative
staining
and we looked at microsatellite stable
versus microsatellite unstable
groups of these of these colon tumor
samples
so as i mentioned we recently came out
with a quant studio 67 pro
uh real-time system this is our flagship
uh quant
real-time pcr system and we have
introduced
several new features that make this uh
easy
easier for you to use in laboratory one
of them is that it has facial
recognition and voice commands
so you can respond to your face or
our voice commands um freeing up your
hands for doing
uh uh other things um it uh introduces
rfid uh plate readers so that on an rfid
tag um there are certain um things that
can be coded and
automatically uploaded into the
instrument i'll have more to say about
that in a second
um it's a true standalone operation with
no external computer needed
um it facilitates tech support by
having uh direct contact with tech
support
and readily downloadable files by tech
support team
to to help speed resolution of technical
problems
um and there are other things you can
read here block
ease of changing cloud connectivity
um instrument connect monitoring
all these things uh help make this
instrument
very easy to use and uh and
take your pcr experiments to the next
level
now as i mentioned the quant studio 67
pro comes with rfid
tagging um this is a radio frequency tag
that is embedded into a plate
uh where the the um the rfid
enables the smart workflow the smart
workflow
the rfid can it can include the plate
layout
all the assay information and run method
all in this rfid tag
it can be get immediately transferred to
the eds file
after the run is completed and and um
when you're running started it will be
uploaded to the instrument so you just
have to basically
put it in and and and turn it on and go
attackman assays in these rfid tag
plates are pre-spotted on the plate
and so it's very convenient then you
just add your sample and master mix and
you're off to the races
and then finally the data analysis is
very easy because you don't have to
download tacman files and upload
a plate layout once the experiment is
complete the data is immediately
analyzable because the eds file
contains all the important information
about the uh the
location of the assays and the run that
was done
so um it's the most simplified workflow
as shown here on the left-hand side of
this
this slide so
um what we did was that we used these
two publications to
to uh order rfid tagged plates
that had these two signatures embedded
in them
one of the signatures was based on an
heirs at all publication that came out
in jay
um journal of clinical investigation
2017.
um this this is a t cell and flame gene
expression signature that predicted
response to pd-1 inhibitors
again you can go back to the original
publication to find out what these genes
actually were but
this is one subset of the genes that we
that we put into the
into the into the plate
another publication came out of the
group uh shikhala at
um at al shikla shukla at all um
this was published in cell last or in
2018.
um in this in this publication they
looked at
a set of germline antigen genes that
particular resistance
that predict resistance to ctl for uh
responsiveness
um so eight different genes that that
were um were
indicative of how well the ctla4 was
going to be able to work in those cells
we also had housekeeping genes um that
were that
eight different housekeeping genes
included in the reference plate and so
we
uh ordered these rfid tagged plates that
had both the pdl1
i'm sorry the pd1 inhibitors and the
ctla inhibitors
embedded in them we then analyze those
those 10
on tumor and adjacent normal genes
colon tumor samples
and look at the differences in
expression patterns that we were able to
see
so at first on uh in the t cell and
flame gene expression
set when we looked at tumor versus
normal
we saw that there's a significant
difference in the t cell inflamed
gene signature in the tumor samples
compared to the normal samples
that we found by it by doing some
statistical analysis of these that the
difference is statistically significant
with a p level of 0.02 here you can see
that the um the the overall uh
signature of the genes not every gene
but this signature in general was was
was upregulated by reflecting of
its lower ct score these genes were
upregulated in the tumor cells versus
the normal cells
so no real surprise there we'd expect
there to be some of the tumor genes that
would be responsive to
to pdl one
if we made the same comparison looking
at the crma genes
the crma is par uh what the others uh
subset of gene expression the
other subset of genes we're looking at
the gene expression of in that
um taqman plate we found there is no
statistically different expression
of the crma genes when we just look at
tumor versus normal research
samples so here we did not see that
there was a difference in
in and in the comparison of just looking
at normal versus tumor
now when we we wanted to look at
the the pdl ones positive
tumor cells and see if we could see
differences in expression
um if we now grade them or or
differentiate them based on cdl i'm
sorry
pdl1 staining versus no staining and so
we sent the samples off to a third party
to to get
staining here we can see an h a um a
hematoxylin eosin staining of a normal
colon
antipedial one standing of this of an
adjacent section and no antibody of an
adjacent section here
and this is this is from the the tumor
um that was
adjacent to the normal tissue um here we
see the h e staining
there's uh pdl1 staining throughout this
particular sample and
again that's specific to the antibody
because no antibody didn't show any
staining at all
so now if we if we look at um the pdl
one positive versus
vl1 negative staining we can see that
the t cell signature is significantly
higher in the pdl1 stain samples versus
versus uh pdl1 positive versus pdl1
negative samples
but again when we look at focusing on
the crma subset of the genes we don't
see a difference
in in crma gene expression
when we look at pdl one when we compare
pl1 positive to pdl1 negative stained
samples again not a terrible surprise
since
we expect that there'd be some t-cell
infiltration causing up regulation
of the t cell um
inflammation specific genes
now last thing i'm going to i'm going to
talk about is the um the
micro satellite status of these samples
for this we turned to our true mark
microsatellite instability assay
this is an assay released last year that
is
a way to look at 13 different
microsatellite markers
it makes use of as little as two
nanograms of ffpe derived dna
and we have facilitated the analysis of
of uh msa stable and unstable with uh
with
customized software and one particular
aspect of the software is that we
don't require there to be a matched
normal sample
for the analysis we make use of an
extensive database of normal samples to
to
come up with the normal samples that our
software uses now again in this case
here we did have normal samples that we
that we're able to compare to
and to make the micro satellite calls
and we did that um for for the
experience i'll tell you about here
overall you can extract dna and get an
answer as little as four hours
with less than one hour hands-on time
and this runs on the seek studio and
other 3 500
genetic analyzers so it's a ce based
micro satellite instability assay
and so we use this assay then to to uh
differentiate a micro satellite stable
for microsoft unstable
tumor samples here and when we look at
the msi
uh we look at the the t
cell inflammation gene expression
signature
in micro satellite high versus
microsatellite stable
samples we don't see a difference in
expression
of that particular signature but when we
look at the signature of the crma
genes we do see that there's a
difference in the microsatellite
unstable samples
we see that there's a lower expression
of the crma genes whereas in the
microsatellite stable
tumors there is an upregulation of this
set of crma genes
this suggests that in the tumor cells
that are microsatellite stable
they might be resistant to blockage uh
using ctla um antagonists
whereas the the microsatellite high
samples um might might be affected
by ctla blockage so this is this might
be a way then to
to distinguish between the way that the
uh
um the cells these cells might respond
to a
uh immune ecology
blocker i um
so this this talk we talked about ways
you can use attackman uh gene expression
panel to differentiate uh
the way that the tumor samples might be
able to respond to an immune oncology
treatment
in these experiments we made use of some
of the smart features of the quant
studio 67 pro and our
rfid tagged plates that really helped
facilitate the speed at which this work
was done because we didn't have to mess
with
uploading tacman sam attackman assay
identifications and mapping them to a
plate etc that was all done on the rfa
detect
these rfid tag plates can be custom
ordered from us
and they'll be pre-spotted with with any
taqman assay
i showed you that gene expression
signature discovery analysis can be an
important part of an oncology research
program
and panels that contain tagline assays
for sets of genes
can define a signature and can be used
for these immunocollageal
immune oncological research results
i want to emphasize these uh these um
these panels and everything here is for
research use only
and not for uh in diagnostic use
finally i want to to acknowledge harita
viruslingam a member of my team who did
all of the work here and comey of arma
on whose
watch this work was performed and thank
you very much for your time